bon maintenant ils vont vous éteignez la
lumière chez vous et ici aussi
jean marie messier questions simples
quoi que vous disiez est ce que vous
pensez sérieusement qu alain de greef
est encore l'homme de la situation en
tant que directeur des programmes de
canal plus ce que je crois c'est que
alain de greef et un d'un homme de
programme remarquable par seulement
derrière pour les programmes de canal+
mais pour l'ensemble des chaînes
thématiques et des différentes offres de
canal est l autre ambition pour lui le
c'est pas mon ambition pour lui c'est le
choix qu'il doit faire il ya un truc qui
est bien c'est que on entend beaucoup de
critiques sur npa en disant mais c'est
dépassé ça a changé et c'est tout
d'abord moi je suis pas nostalgique
gildas de caunes c'était génial dujon
c'est pas mal du tout et il ya un truc
qui est simple canal ça toujours été à
la pointe de l'innovation
on le doit de greffe et de greffe encore
énormément de choses à porter canal n'y
pas de doute là dessus